it's great to be joined today by Anthony
scuze who is an Australia based
political scientist blogger and also
author of politics for the new Dark Age
staying positive amidst disorder which
we will get to Anthony so as you know I
came across your article about the
intellectual dark web an article will
act which actually happened to quote me
but that's not why you're actually on
the program it was a great article
regardless of that just so everybody
knows and what I found interesting about
your critique was that it matched up
with one particular element of my
critique of the intellectual dark web
which is that there's a lot of
rebranding and packaging and optics at
play for ideas that are not only not
unique but in some cases genuinely bad
or debunked ideas so let's maybe start
there what do you see as sort of the
crux of this movement that is the
so-called intellectual dark web
thanks David I think that's a really
interesting question and I the reason
why I wrote about this group was to try
and figure about out about what made
them distinctive and what made them
intellectually interesting if anything
and I think when you look at the merits
of it exactly as you say a lot of the
ideas that they're promoting very old
ideas from within the more conservative
side of liberalism and the libertarian
tradition and really ideas that have
been discussed and debated for many
years and I don't think the the free
speech warrior sort of narrative is is
very helpful either because empirically
of course these people extremely well
heard they have massive audiences and so
to other people that are protesting them
the people that challenge they have used
the people that critique they're at
their opinions and I think overall
institutions and society as a whole has
well-functioning institutional
mechanisms that are sort of on the whole
can be improved but overall able to
resolve these disputes about who gets to
speak and who gets to speak where and
when to sort of the satisfaction of
everybody involved so the thesis that I
develop in the blog article that you
came across is that the right that the
intellectual dark web is asserting is
not
they're right to free speech at all but
rather the right to protect their
reputation to the right to their good
names to their honor and their prestige
and that they're asserting that when
there's a conflict between their good
name between their reputation and the
free speech of others that their right
to their good name should ultimately
prevail
and this is I think what explains the
asymmetry between these you know this
this group of academics and media
personalities and their critics is that
our student protesters don't have you
know socially meaningful reputations
that can be infringed often minority
groups because of their perceived lower
social rank are used to having the you
know the culture and their social
behaviors critiqued in a way that
doesn't you know involve besmirching the
honor of the group as a whole
whereas I think the intellectual darkweb
the academics peterson harris and these
science types of people are asserting
that their reputations are worth
protecting and that they're claiming a
right which you know men and women of
their class and their social status and
let's be honest their race have been
able to assert for centuries and that is
to hold and express any of you in public
whatsoever without suffering any adverse
reputational consequences yeah and that
gets to this confusion that exists in a
lot of places between the fact that one
has a right to speak versus that they
are not exempt from the consequences of
that speech and maybe we'll get to that
one of the things I wanted to run by you
is that you know one of the under the
guise of this free speech and a battle
of ideas marketplace of ideas kind of
meme that has developed from the
intellectual dark web
I actually identify that many of the
positions that they are sort of claiming
are either heavily attacked positions
stigmatized positions positions which
there are authoritarian anti-free speech
elements that are really opposed to
they're not really positions that are
actually that controversial in other
words myself as like a progressive call
me whatever you want ready progressive
Social Democrat
in favor of you know equality feminism
and egalitarian it whatever right
characterize me however I agree with a
lot of the basics of what the so called
intellectual dark web is fighting for
which is there shouldn't really be taboo
subjects which can't be discussed it
should be okay to point out when one
religious group or another has ideas
that we might consider counter to the
best interests of society like these
things aren't even really that
controversial it's more the idea that
they've created an atmosphere where they
claim that it's not okay to talk about
this stuff when for the most part it's
fine to talk about this stuff yeah
that's exactly right and that really
gets back to the sort of the lack of
intellectual novelty of anything that
these characters are saying you know
it's been this all ultimately goes back
to a question of inequality and what
does inequality mean under a sort of a
liberal social order in which sort of
everyone is theoretically entitled to
the same rights and equal dignity and I
think what the intellectual darkweb and
sort of their intellectual predecessors
are really asserting is more or less a
standard set of positions sort of
right-wing liberalism has come to over
the last 50 years ever since Hayek and
Nozik and very Marie and rothbard and
that is a mix of libertarianism I this
idea that liberalism is ultimately all
about choice and that we judge
inequality based on the basis of whether
or not it respects that choice as well
as often a sort of consequentialist or
utilitarian logic which argues it well
inequality is not necessarily good but
sometimes it can be justified for the
good of the economy as a whole
and beyond that I I don't hear Harris or
Mari or pink sorry Harris or Pinker or
Jordan Peterson asserting any
perspective that is anything more
controversial than the standard
positions that are taught in
universities all all around the Western
world I was recently reading an article
that sought to sort of discuss what
environmental circumstances lead to a
rise in what the article called Charla
ten ISM and it pointed out interestingly
that for example when we started to see
modern medicine develop but before we
really knew
like what's quackery and what's real
modern medicine it gave rise to a ton of
so-called snake oil salesmen people
selling all sorts of you know liquids
herbs whatever right and that because
there was a very rapid increase in the
amount of information that there was to
read about or find out about because of
this acceleration of medical
circumstances it actually made it
possible for the charlatans to sort of
get in there because people are less
able to distinguish between all of this
new stuff that's available and thus at
the same time that there was like modern
medicine being developed there was a lot
of quackery that was perceived as maybe
equally valid is there an analogy from
that to what we're seeing now linking
sort of for example like the Trump
presidency and this post truth
alternative facts era and the pickup the
stickiness of the intellectual dark web
yeah I think it's actually an excellent
analogy and if you don't mind I just
want to sort of step back and sort of
explain how I see this fitting into sort
of a broader research area my sort of
general intellectual interest is in
culture as an evolutionary system so
this idea that cultural norms and
behavior evolve and change in accordance
with the mathematical laws of natural
selection so that the area's behavioral
mutation which leads to novel behaviors
and novel strategies some of those
strategies are more successful than
others and are therefore differentially
or preferentially copied in the next
generation now when it comes to humans
as a social species one of the main way
in which people learn new behaviors and
gain new information is by imitation we
copy what other people do because on the
whole it's more efficient when it room
to do as the Romans do rather than
trying to use our brains and sort of tax
our intellectual resources to come up
with the most efficient efficient social
strategy on our the problem is imitation
creates its own set of social dilemmas
the question is who do we copy who is
worthy of imitation who has the best
information whose theory of the case is
the most scientifically informed or the
best best tested by evidence and exactly
as you pointed out there's often an
advantage for people to have their
strategy copied and they may have
incentives to deceive about the
reliability of the evidence on which
their theory is based or the
effectiveness of the strategies that
there are commit that they're
recommending so the theory of who do we
copy from and who is worthy of imitation
and who is worthy of learning is really
important to understanding how cultural
evolution works and there are four basic
mechanisms that sort of mathematically
can be shown to work in this regard
they're sort of cute trusts based on kid
networks I I trust and copy you because
you're my relative there's Network
reciprocity where I trust or I copy your
behavior because we are physically
proximate to one another
there's record reputation mechanisms
basically I copy your behavior because
your high status person in my society
and I know that you have been successful
in the past and the fourth and final one
is is group identity I the behavior of
other people and my identity group
because that group enos is what makes us
successful and so looking at reputation
and the importance of reputation in
terms of social reproduction and how
ideas spread throughout the societies I
think vastly important because although
reputation isn't important in one
societies in a lot of ways I would argue
that in the culture industry where the
intellectual darkweb primarily comes
from places like academia places like
media and social media in particular
reputation is still very important and
it is important to academics it is
important to media personalities that
they be seen and perceived to have high
level levels of prestige and high levels
of trust because that's the way that
they ensure that their ideas are
propagated in the limited time we have
left I do want to touch on the book a
little bit I regularly hear from people
who are of two mindsets right now in
this sort of current world of politics
one is they're more engaged than ever
because they feel a more acute need to
try to get in the way of what they see
is
really negative turns that society and
culture have taken others though are
opting to opt out altogether because
it's just so difficult and horrifying
and depressing and they're saying I'm
just gonna stop paying attention to
politics and hope I kind of get through
my life in an okay way what would be
your approach in terms of how to be
engaged in a way that's maybe not
depressing or whatever word we want to
apply to it I I think you can probably
tell from my use of evolutionary
paradigms and I I'm fairly comfortable
with conflict I you know I'm used to
thinking of politics and of culture as
conflictual systems and sort of the
optimistic way of looking at their
systems this is say yes it's brutal
yes it's often competitive you know
often the social equilibrium that occur
and not the social equal equilibria that
we would want but over the long arc of
human history you do see social progress
come out of their systems because
evolution is a learning system that does
increase the complexity of information
it does increase the level of
cooperativeness and the scale at which
human societies can organize so if
you're looking for a positive message
about how far we've come as a species
and and what we can achieve I think you
know thinking of society and politics as
conflictual is is not necessarily a net
negative and so I wrote the book to
really provide a sort of a step-by-step
way of sort of leading people from that
view of politics as conflictual and
showing sort of moving from issue to
issue how you can go from that to sort
of seeing trust and social cooperation
as the basis of the politics that we
need for the future the book is politics
for the new Dark Age staying positive
amidst disorder we're linking to it in
the description for the YouTube video
we've been speaking with the book's
author Anthony Skewes who's an Australia
based political scientist blogger and
author Anthony thank you so much for
talking to us today thanks very much
David it was pleasure